to look at for
like forever forever
and it's come up in context recently
of some physics project work and that's
caused
me at least to figure out that there are
in a sense simpler ways
to handle some of the key questions in
logic programming
um basic issue is
given a set
of um given a set of rules
how do you uh
collect them together to get from one
place to another and
let's take a look here
now this isn't adequate i mean what what
hold on development
um
okay what is the
i don't know what exactly is different
between manu's version of this
and so i had a version then we had a
version that's based on multiverse
systems
then we had various other versions
uh find string replace path
so let's take a look at what these
things actually do
let's look at find string replace path
to begin with
um
right so the idea is
that we are given a collection of rules
like here let's just say
um right this is a reasonable example
okay oh yeah
okay so people understand what this is
doing yes
this is saying what's a way of putting
together those rules
to get from a to b right
yes understand no
okay okay
um but now
you know back in the day right
people were obsessed i mean this is now
we're now talking 25 years ago or more
people are obsessed with prologue and
its way of doing
uh you know sort of goal-based
programming right
and now
we have a um machine learning
function don't we that is um that is
doing something a little bit like this
let me just see uh
this is
yes so
to what extent does active okay if we
say
active prediction right active
prediction
let's see how does this work
um
applies the function to successively
generate configurations
starting from one of these these things
so to what extent is this the same idea
do we understand that do we know that
anybody got an opinion um i
i don't it's the first time i i'm seeing
these functions
okay that it doesn't seem that that
function is applied multiple times
is that right i mean it is in other
words is it
i see you think
all right so it may not be related let's
let me
just save this away in some appropriate
place
let's see if we have stuff from like
millions of years ago
oh wow we have a thing called logic
programming here oh one
let's let's make a um
let's just take a look at that thing in
a minute
um
just for the hell of it let's find out
what we wrote probably many years ago
here
um about the same topic hold on one
second
oh yeah five years ago let me put in
that folder
um
okay this was written in 2015.
oh my gosh we had the exact same
function
we had the exact same function well
that's a good sign
honestly that's a pretty good sign yep
wow we just didn't implement it
um okay
so
so then we had this idea
um okay a find
goal sequence where there are
uh scores
i mean this first one is
so so okay so this this relates to what
you can do
in kind of multi-way in the multi-way
games business i don't know how the
scores really
really relate here so so we
i'm actually very pleased that the
function is exactly it's exactly the
same
function i am at least deterministic
if even if nothing else is here um
ethan is commenting that active
prediction active classification both
impossible to use
in real machine learning problems and
need rewrites well be interesting to get
input about why um
they have not been popular functions
that is for sure
um and i don't really understand what
um okay so it's hold on a second but
let's just um
uh uh what was i looking at i was
looking for
the multi-way games business which
i think will be helpful here um
see
hold on
just a second i need to find this
um oh dear where did i put it
oh here we go well i don't know which
which version of this i should look at
but let's try
randomly a particular one
okay so this is looking at
this is okay so this is this is
simplified tic-tac-toe
okay and so the find replace path
would be something that says can you get
to the winning state
and the scoring is a question of knowing
whether you're getting warmer so to
speak it's a hint
right it doesn't it's not well
i mean i guess that this is related to
okay so hold on a second
so the issues here are um can use
you know okay so case case one there is
a definitive end point
okay um or maybe or possibly
or possibly or possibly a
uh um a pattern
for the end point am i making sense
that is that there could be several
different possible
um endpoints but they all have a certain
pattern form
and then case two which segues into more
of a machine learning story
one just wants to find
the highest score endpoint
right so that's the case where you've
got these rules
and you're you've got a scoring function
and you're asking
how do i apply these rules to get to
the highest and that's that's
almost a traditional you know
optimization machine learning type
problem
this also reminds me of the problem in
group theory of given generators
find that the composition of a given
element in generators
yes yes that's true so so given
i mean but that's okay so let's let's
list some of the things that
um uh use cases
okay so i agree that
given a word slash
path or path in a group
decompose it into generators
now is that is that the same
thing because what you're asking for
there
okay so that's a little different
because in this case yeah i guess
you can always do that by saying there's
a rule let's let's look at that for a
second
so the rule you okay in this case
your um
in this case it's like the strings
you're adding to the strings here yeah
it's really very much like this this is
like a semi groups
that's like that's like a monoid right
the string case
right is like a monoid version
now you know jonathan for example has
multi-way group which presumably
essentially does
is does this right
uh yeah so
my question um
you know there's a question here of what
what is the universe of things okay so
let's take a look what we did in 2015 of
um
our you know different use cases here
okay so we've got
on the group theory front if you'll
recall this is the thing that i think
you and i had a disagreement about
in the design of multi-way group
well yes well you have this this i was
arguing that we should allow a rule that
where you can basically multiply at
arbitrary positions
because that's effectively doing this
right it allows you to solve a
generalized word problem
in which you're doing decomposition into
generators whereas if you only allow
multiplication on
sort of one side then unless you assume
commutativity or some other nice
sort of algebraic feature you can't do
the same thing
that was not my recollection of
difference i thought you had this
this uh you know novelty generator
where you have a rule that says nothing
goes to
and then various and then you know
nothing goes to a generator
but those are exactly the same right
because if you if you say no
okay so so in in the if you treat the
thing as a as a monoids right there
or if you think if you think of the
thing as a string with a monod structure
where the whether nothing is your
identity
yes then nothing goes to whatever is
exactly the rule that lets you multiply
by a generator in an arbitrary position
okay hold on you're claiming that that
the thing that says essentially nothing
goes to what not nothing goes through
generator nothing goes to a generator
multiplied by its inverse
for sure
no but that's simply an equation right i
mean that that's
that's not a that's there in the axioms
of group theory
yes right what i'm saying is that
when you want to do the decomposition
into generators you
so what i was doing was tagging so there
are
there are several different types of
rewrites in multi-way group right there
are rewrites that are simply
axiomatic like that one there would be
an axiomatic right yeah there are
lights that are as a consequence of the
relations and then there are rewrites
that are a consequence of you
multiplying by a generator at an
arbitrary location i see
so so what you're saying yeah okay
that's a case that you care about when
you want to do a decomposition of a word
into generators
right right so what you're saying is
there's okay so
in multi-way group
there's there are um
basically meaning neutral
transformations
then there are probing transformations
that try to figure out whether whether
whether you can construct a word
that gets you to that particular place
exactly and and so
so your um your design for it which
which is supported uh with with the
option append only if you set append
only to be true then you get your design
which is where you only have the meaning
neutral transformations and multiply on
the right
but then there's then the default is the
full form where you can actually where
you can you can multiply in arbitrary
positions
which has that kind of novelty wait a
minute multiplying in arbitrary
positions kind of violates
the sort of them
i mean that's okay then then then okay
what we're saying is there's the
difference between
it's the it's the old difference between
theorem proving
and uh uh setting up equality
so to speak but it isn't really an
equality in this case it's it's a
yeah okay i understand at least i
understand that better
but so so in a typical case okay so so
let's let's again talk about use cases
here
one one meta use case
um okay here here this there's sort of
another case here maybe
um one wants to find a proof or wants to
find an equivalence proof
so in other words that's a case where
where
in that case every step
is somehow considered equivalent to
every previous one
right so so in other words in this case
it's like one's reaching out from
point a to point b right that's a
definitive you know
you're going um
so that's a find replace path i mean i
don't know
the replace is right there i mean the
general case of this will be find
um uh
it's a general let's see
find operation path or something
um well actually we could call it find
function
path and find function path
is you've got actually that's a
different case right i mean they're the
um okay instead of replacements at all
right there yes there's a different
thing here
so okay so i'm gonna claim there's
find replace path
there's find string replace path
and there's find function path
okay find function path would be
f g h x
y
i think so f
so find replace path and find string
replace path would just be special cases
of find function path
for repo that's correct but probably
which probably can be done much more
efficiently in various ways
right steven you were saying when you
find an equivalence proof
that each step has to be reversible but
i don't think
i don't think it has to be that strict i
mean the forward path and backward path
might be completely different
and still get equivalents fair point
fair point though the
okay which will which will in general be
the case if you have um
uh sort of generated variables on one
side of an equation
right right right right right
in can i make a meta comment here
i mean there are a bunch of other things
that one can do with logic programming
and like for example
in general one is interesting knowing if
something
a theorem so
if something can be achieved with a set
of replacement rules
or even enumerating all possible things
and another important case i think is
unification
so figuring out when you when you're
matching a replacement
what you know what gets unified with
what
right actually okay so so this
okay so there's a case two a
here find an
end point that
uh satisfies
a uh a
a a criterion eg tic-tac-toe
yeah or for example einstein problems
you wanna know
you know who lives where even
what the the the einstein problem you
know that
the person who lives in the yellow house
is next to blah blah blah where does
john live
that kind of constraint solving that's
also often done with
right or sudoku whatever
you want to know what number goes where
right so this is
well you you need to know the path in
other words
i mean the path is not that relevant
there and in many cases there might be
multiple solutions it's not difficult of
course of course
of course i mean in find replace path
find string replace path we have
something
if we look here um
what's this
oh that's the
definition i've never heard of
einstein's riddle before
wow i wonder whether old albert actually
wrote this himself
i it's weird because i thought you
taught me
the name einstein problem when we were
talking about
mini cameron but maybe it was somebody
else i think so think of somebody else
because i don't think i ever do this
um the uh
okay in any case what we've done in find
string replace path
we do have the ability to find like all
paths
and the multi-way fragment that
describes so this is something for
discrete paths
that makes decent sense but i think i
think we're always dealing with discrete
parts i think that's the only case of
relevance here yeah but i mean you have
to know what the solution is right
well no but i mean we're saying that
that in all of these cases
you want an endpoint satisfies a request
criterion you had
one of the highest score et cetera et
cetera but now
you were talking about unification so
let's talk about that
carla's making the point that an
endpoint that satisfies a criterion
will in general not be a literal string
it will be some equivalence class of
strings
which we don't have the ability to
specify either here or in the theorem
improving framework
right it's a different okay well okay so
let's okay so hold on a second so then
like
so the theorem prover can solve logic
puzzles if you tell it the solution
right so it can it can check if you get
if you set up an einstein riddle
it will tell you that the solution is
correct if you give it one but it can't
generate a solution
because that would require and also like
the einstein riddle is usually expressed
in terms of constraints
not in terms of replacement rules the
replacement rules are kind of trivial
for the einstein thing and it's the same
with sudoku
like okay well let's talk about how that
looks what that looks like
okay so
find function path specifies a bunch of
moves
that are legal moves to make so
an alternative would be yet a different
case here which is some kind of find
constraint
path where what you're doing is you're
saying
you can make um you can
so where you both have okay so so there
maybe it's folded in with this you have
a uh generator of motions
you have a constraint
that it must satisfy
so in other words you're not saying
explicitly what
um and i think that's similar to what
active predict prediction so on tries to
do
and maybe doesn't get to do a good job
is that right i mean this is the so so
in this case you have a local constraint
yes or no
that right i mean the
the that constraint is intended to be a
constraint on each
application of the motion is that
correct
well well if you think about sudoku it's
usually uh
the it's uh on the end result like
whether or not it's the
value but that's a different case that's
a case we've already talked about here
which is the endpoint satisfies a
criterion yeah but not just the end
point
every every time you add the number the
board has to stay valued then that's
what this is
yeah that's what it is it must satisfy
at every step
right okay so so jonathan was showing
here
a
so okay let's understand your comment
about unification okay so
what should i look at here if i look at
there was something i sent
to you in 2018 mail title mini cameron
which contains a notebook
that should be okay let's i'll find it
it's only only two years ago
uh i didn't work on it two years ago it
was
longer ago than that but i sent it to
you do you think it's one word
in 2018 february 2018 title mini can run
well if you
if you have it then then
there we go from carlo here we go
tutorial equivalence i remember you
showing me the mini cameron
implementation you had back in the like
the 2017 summer school
okay all right so this is your mini
cannon thing so let's take a look at
this
so one thing that it does in terms of of
unification for example is that if you
give it
an under constrained um sudoku
it will still find solution and say you
know
this is the set of solutions hold on
hold on hold on hold on
um
okay so let's look at this
let me ask this question in terms of
just practicality of implementing these
things
does i mean did you integrate mini
cameron in some way with the system
no the i mean the code that is there is
like about 150 lines of code
but it's not efficient at all like if i
were to go back and write this again i
would probably
you know now z3 from microsoft is mit
licensed
so maybe it's something that we should
look into this would be much much faster
is okay can somebody walk me through
what the relationship
between our equation approver and z
z3 and so on is
z3 is a constraint programming system
yes
it it also has theorem proving i don't
know what flavor
and a set solder okay we already have a
sat solver
we already have a good sat solver that's
not that's not the problem we're trying
to solve here
i mean this does this need sat solving
somewhere in the middle of it
no i mean this this is something
okay so then then let's just understand
okay so the main point here
is we want to get you know
convenient design so so to me
there are several different things you
want to get out of this
you might want to just say okay so in
other words
in these use cases here right so
meta use cases you know
uh which of a class of end points
can i actually reach
is there a path
maybe how long is the path maybe i don't
know how the
that's um maybe that's maybe less less
important that's a meta question really
is there a path what is the path
what is the e.g shortest
path perhaps variant
is what is the path
that optimizes uh such and such a
criterion
am i making sense in other words that um
uh if there are multiple paths to choose
from length might not be uh so really
what we want
is a is a um
a criterion for choosing paths right
criterion for choosing between paths
and that might be a local criterion
saying
don't step on the hot lava or try not to
if you can avoid it
and it might be a a global constraint
that says
i want the shortest overall path
does that make sense and
let's let's just look for a second back
at our um
can i can i say something before we move
on before you put
mini cameron behind uh why
i want to i want i'm going to come to
mini canada i wanted to talk
specifically about mini cannon
just a second i just want to look at our
next states and scores
okay okay
okay so these are examples that we had
from before
of um
um hold on i just have to
organize my
um
okay so these are
from before some use cases here
chemical synthesis which we've now
discussed at more length
we've got a variety of game solving
which is mostly i would say i mean and
then
you know and then the various kinds of
planning problems
um
yeah brian's asking about chess problems
yeah i mean this is exactly the
that's the type of problem that this
should be able to do
and that's like the eight queens case is
a common test case
can we already do eight queens with with
them
presumably can the theorem prove it do
that
yeah but like i said i mean it it can it
can check solutions that already exist
but what you what basically the key
thing that z3 and mini cameron and these
other kinds of logic programming
languages do the arthur improve it
doesn't do
is have the ability to basically
generate uh
to generate proofs of theorems where
parts of the theorem are underspecified
right okay all right generating
you know generating proofs
where um where the
the okay where where the the
end point is not definite is that what
you're saying
right right okay so this is actually
this is a general difference between
theorem provers
you know theorem verifiers and logic
programming languages so like
uh mini camera you know there's this
thing called alpha lean tap which is a
sort of
uh nominal logic proving environment in
mini cameron
um and so you can give it a theorem and
it will give you a proof so it's in that
sense as a regular theorem proverb but
on the other hand if you give it a proof
it will give you the associated theorem
so you can use it to check proofs
but also it can do a hybrid where if you
give it sort of part of a proof and part
of a theorem
it can fill in missing pieces so you can
use it on
exploration wait a minute given a proof
it will give you the theorem why isn't
the theorem just
beginning of proof equals under proof
uh it is if the proof is correct
there is i mean the stuff that mini
cameron is i think
where it's very different from from our
theory improver is that you can do
things like for example you
you can ask to generate wines
for example generally what quines
yeah so you can you can if you
it i mean at least in its original
implementation in scheme
it knows about the scheme syntax at
least part of it
and so it can generate programs in
scheme that satisfy a
frugal double i mean that i know yes you
can generate combinator expressions too
no doubt with with any of these things
we've got a you know
a multi-way combinator system too that
the question of what the syntax of what
it's generating is
it doesn't seem terribly important
there is a there is a more fundamental
point right which is that the the this
function this sort of
super function in mini cameron evalo
which which lets you relate
you know an expression to what value it
evaluates to the fact that
one or both sides of an ivalo expression
can be underspecified
means it is strictly stronger than a
theorem prover right
okay all right so let's let's where the
where the end points are not definite so
what you're saying is
there's i'm trying to reduce this to
like functions here so i mean
what you're saying is find find function
path
where well find no i'm saying something
much stronger than that
no you're saying that you've got an
initial condition that satisfies you
know got you got basically
um i don't know what the right name for
it but let's let's say find constraint
path and then the initial condition is
specified by
init crit and final crit
if i'm understanding correctly those are
those are criteria
as opposed to um as opposed to being a
definite thing is that right or is that
not right well as i say i'm saying
something much stronger than that
so what what what mini cameron can do is
it's not just finding paths
it can it can it can deal with the the
hybrid case
of you have this partially specified
path and a partially specified
uh sort of set of criteria and it will
fill in the blanks in both
and and the other thing is that the
rules well that's magic but how would we
represent it
no wait i think that the first problem
is to represent the rules in a similar
way to
how mini cameron does okay you know what
you know what guys guys
look look we have a nice general
symbolic way of representing things
the goal is not to you know descend into
some
thing which is hardly you know a
consumer used
you know mechanism what we want to do is
not
this type of thing where we're setting
up some complicated state
no no but in the end i mean those i was
explaining those
as uh but if you look those are internal
tools if you look at two goals
what mini canon the way you express
rules in mini cameron is strictly
two-way
and it's basically you're you you can
unify replacement rules in both
directions
that's the big difference so if you look
at the one just above
just two goals
where are we looking here just after set
uh blah blah blah
oh two goals here we go okay so you're
saying
i have a sequence of integers on the
left and
on the right i have just a blank
with uh um a pattern test
what are the ways in which i can choose
x and y to
satisfy this equation and then it just
goes and generates
x and y's so it's not okay okay i
understand so that's like find instance
or something
right so there's a there's a find
instance case
right so so stephen the at least in the
in the context of the theorem proving
stuff
the most direct translation of the kind
of of something like an evalo
um operation in in wl would be to have
the ability to have a partially
specified proof
object and then a function that then
fills in the detail so where either the
axioms or the theorem or the proof
can be underspecified yes i understand i
mean my concern is how on earth to
specify that whether it's with patterns
or whether it's
something more general so
i would say patterns or an explicit
quantification would be the obvious way
to do it or
i mean from a logic and and also i think
rather than
i mean it's actually a little bit less
than patterns because our patterns are
too general
to to be able to deal with like no
our patterns have undecidability which
you know
so but that's like the pattern but you
see
but carlo carlo the problem with this is
and this is what killed prologue as a
practical thing
is that you know it's very easy to
specify things
that are extremely hard to do
so the challenge for us is to
figure out ways to specify useful things
that are still doable and that's why for
example find
things like find string replace path or
find replace path
is a nice doable thing right it's a nice
thing where people can understand what
the point is and you can actually do
it yeah now i mean as soon as you
descend
into you've got arbitrary programming on
both sides
no you can't do it and and you have to
go ahead anyway yeah you can't do it and
there's another
thing that makes it i mean the way i
restricted the problem
uh and it was hard enough this way is
um i mean the main hurdle i had to
compare to to scheme is the fact that
expressions
in the wolfram language can have and and
patterns can have
arbitrary arbitrary length sequences
while
in scheme everything is a binary tree
okay
and so when
that seems like okay but you also talked
about unification which is not
completely dissimilar to this issue here
i mean i'm trying to well that's
that's unification yeah i mean that that
particular thing doesn't have a
unification that solves
it but if you have if you look at the
the one
there is uh one below which is just
eq check qy that thing is just
it has one free variable which is q and
it's trying to find the solution
q equal y and the only solution it can
find
is a blank that is since also y is not
specified
it finds a pattern and the one below
it finds two two solutions
it finds an alternative oh yeah but but
so in our world
what this is doing is solving a pattern
equation
now i mean we've worked on so so there
was a project
long-running project done by a uh
student person um which was a string
equation solver okay which was quite
difficult
used some quite fancy algorithms i'm not
sure it's even now been put even in the
function repository
because it had you know there were only
specific string patterns
okay so this is also i just want to make
a note this is also related to
um uh this thing is related to
oops this thing is related to string
solve
but but so that's a you know honestly
this is a different problem i think
from these path related problems there's
a whole class of problems
that are you apply this function this
function this function you're trying to
get to this place
right and i'm not quite understanding
and then there's something where you say
given these two patterns
what is their you know what is their
overlap basically
yeah right and that that to me is a
slightly different
um you know that would be something like
pattern solve
so i i should mention that at least in
the case of the the kinds of patterns
that are supported by
multi-way system we have code for
computing mgus
implicitly in canonical branch pairs and
um what's an ngu most general unifiers
mgu sorry i misheard okay
okay so okay so then
if you remember the way that canonical
branch pairs works basically is you you
give it a bunch of string rules or you
know a bunch of multi-way rules
and it looks for the look it finds the
mgu of the left-hand sides
and then uh and then applies all
possible combinations of rules to those
to the unifiers i do remember that yes i
do remember that
um so hold on so how would we make that
into a generally usable function and by
the way these things are also related
you know also related to um the stuff
the um
the sparkle stuff
isn't it where you're trying to find um
um
right i mean uh you're trying to find
parts
that they are related to sparkle uh and
i think that there is on the other hand
there is like i was
telling this to um jose earlier
that there is a there might also be an
application to things like data set
that is you get data in a shape and
you want to normalize it to something
that a function can eat
oh yeah absolutely you want to normalize
it in a way that fits into
you know these normal forms that
databases it because that's what
sparkle is doing basically it's
denormalizing actually but
well or alternatively you know you you
have a form of visualization that's a
histogram
and you've got this data how can you get
it into that form yeah
yeah and that's the original reason why
i started studying mini cameron
no i understand i was working on alpha
right i remember but but so what we've
got to do here
you know the design challenge here is to
turn this into probably i'm guessing on
the order
of four functions that are
you know that do the things you want to
do i mean personally i think pattern
unification
is not as practically important as some
of these pathfinding things
i mean in other words that you know the
thing you want out
from let's let's imagine that we say
find function path
okay and okay so let's imagine that find
function path
is um okay so this is a good example
actually
is is given all kinds of things that say
transpose
of blah comma blank blank
whatever right and it's also given
reverse and it's also given
i don't know what a ray flatten
a blah with blanks you see what i'm
saying
okay so now the question is and you've
given some data data one
and you're given a a pattern
for data two either a pattern
or a criterion for data two
right and you're asked so then the
result you might want to get here
is a path that says transpose on axis ii
drop blah blah blah you get what i'm
saying to get
from data one to something that
satisfies the criterion or matches that
pattern
does that make sense to people
i mean that seems to me to be a
practical thing that we might want
and and and you know let's compare this
compare to simplify okay so full
simplify
is doing something very much like that
except that it has
um you know it has a cost goal it has a
cost function
right now i mean i don't know what
whether you know maybe even this
technology could be used by full
centrify full simplify i don't know how
sophisticated it's some
um okay so so what another one
is let's see to what extent is fine
distribution also
a a thing related to this is this is
this some
uh okay so we've got things like full
simplify
um uh
how is fine distribution related to this
because in fine distribution
you're essentially i have to go to a
different meeting in just a second here
um this is a terrific topic and we need
to continue it and i think we're going
to get something i mean
between so we've got you know
our technologies here just to summarize
we've got multi-way system is one
technology
we've got find equational proof there's
another technology
we've got you know z3 slash mini cameron
what other technologies do we have that
are relevant to this
there is data log which is a lot more
related to the kind of
data set like transformation on top of
data
okay but what other do we have other
internal technology
that is relevant to this maybe although
we don't really understand it
um activeclassify in relation to groups
again we have group element word
which decompose any any group element
into
generators
okay and and in relation to that so
these
find path functions should they return
the list of states
or the list of steps you've got to be
able to ask for both of them
okay right i think we've got to be able
to you know the length the end point
the steps i mean this is this is this is
the notion of event specification
you know the the the things you apply
are the events
the states you get to are the states if
you understand what i'm saying
and in in the multi-way system case we
understand we need both of those
and we have developed quite quite i mean
and there's also things you might want
like the branch pairs
right that would be a useful thing to to
um
you know the result might need
yeah i mean the all the things that we
need in instrumenting multi-way systems
are potentially useful here
right but but then you're in the world
of of computing mgus
and things no doubt but i mean but the
point
jonathan is this my point is how do we
make something that's understandable and
useful to people
and and these things like find a path
that's understandable
these things where you're
you know anyway okay i have to go
unfortunately
um it's a terrific conversation and we
need to continue it
but not today um so thanks all
and uh see you later and thank you to
folks on the live stream here actually
hold on a second just let me just look
very very quickly at um
um
there's a question um inverse kinematics
that's another interesting yes i mean
that's another use case here
is that we should be looking at
um
and um josephus problem
i remember that is an example of this
okay uh
encode constraints and nick says encode
constraints
in a um um
uh in something similar to geometric
scene
oh that's interesting that's another
technology that that's some
that's another technology we have here
is the find instance
slash geometric scene world and i'm
this is i i'd love to continue this but
i really need to go
deal with a much more um
yeah i mean right and this whole
um yeah i mean this is this is a general
category of constraint programming
which we should list here although
what we're doing is breaking that down
um
but for the next time we should start
talking about that
all right thanks guys thanks to folks on
livestream